[Music]
foreign
here on CBS mornings and this summer is
likely to be among the busiest travel
seasons in years so to find out what to
expect we've got an exclusive interview
with Delta Airline CEO Ed Bastian but
first let me run you through the numbers
this month alone the TSA says it's
screened more than 35 million passengers
and the agency is predicting record
numbers could pass through our nation's
airports this summer Delta tells CBS
News it's already getting ready to fly
2.8 million passengers over Memorial Day
weekend and the airline has already
booked 75 percent of its international
flights for the summer so Ed Bastion
joins us now only on CBS mornings thank
you very much for being here yes good to
be with you guys one thing that could
affect all of those travel plans is a
recession particularly a global
recession uh you've said you were not
concerned but now we've got this debt
ceiling debacle looming what's your
message to Washington right now
well certainly separate from the travel
space you know obviously we need our
leaders that we elected to come into
office to continue to run the country
with the rate level of of
both discipline but also you know Common
Sense negotiation to get us to where we
need to be but getting to your question
on the economy the economy is in an
interesting place you know you certainly
have some businesses some industries
that Goods Home Depot yesterday
announced that they were a little short
on their on their revenues I think
people are not buying things as much
they're investing in themselves they're
investing in experience they're
investing in uh premium opportunities
and they had three years to sit and look
at their plans that they wanted to go
and they're out trying to recapture that
and reclaim that that experience and I
know you all travel the planes are full
people are going people are happy to be
getting back to uh reclaim their life
and their joy and work continues that
and I don't see that changing and so
while there will certainly be parts of
the economy that will stumble as you're
already starting to see some cracks I
don't think it's travel travel is
something people are prioritizing and by
the way it's the same in the restaurants
it's the same in the hotels and same
internationally yeah well listen things
have changed for the better but when it
comes to traveling I feel like we are
concerned about oh thank you there Tony
I appreciate it all the people at home
here
where's Tony
um
but when it comes to travel there are
some concerns about disruptions delays
and flight cancellations what are you
doing to make sure your Airlines uh Will
Will Travel smoothly right um in this
upcoming year well last year everyone
remembers how tough it was last summer
it was the first time everyone was ready
to go and everyone decided to go all at
the same time and it really didn't
matter where they were going or how much
they had to pay they just needed to get
out and the airlines struggle because we
were hiring people getting people
trained getting people in position so it
was a rough summer travel season uh we
are not just at Delta but the industry
in such a better shape Delta
specifically we've hired over 25 000
people hired and trained and they're
ready to go they're in position summer
is always busier than other parts of the
year but our team's ready our team's
ready internationally our terms teams
ready in the in the U.S and I think it's
going to be a very very good travel
period well everybody hopes that but the
bite Administration as you know as
proposed regulations that the airlines
be held accountable to compensate
passengers if for hotel rooms for meals
if they're stranded due to the airline's
fault when you first heard that we have
it there on our screen when you first
heard that did you say great idea Mr
President what did you think
well we already do that at Delta you
know we take care of our customers uh
we're known for ourselves we already
provide for them if if there if there is
an issue with your travel that is a
controllable matter weather is obviously
one of the biggest reasons why they're
still laser cancellations that's out of
our control put that on the side right
anything that's within our control we
already do we compensate our customers a
meaningful amount of money whether it's
hotels or meals or or additional impact
items for their for their travels
because we know when you decide what
airline you're choosing you want to make
sure you're choosing an airline that's
got your back and so for us it's second
only to safety is how we recover a
customer's Journey when they when they
we have a different these regulations go
through the other concern is that now it
that those that price is now going to be
passed on to the customers is is that
going to happen do you think well
there's no question if there is another
layer of government regulation and cost
that's introduced into the system it'll
eventually find its way back into ticket
prices that's just common common
business logic was there a knee-jerk
reaction to possibly Lobby against these
these new regulations that providing
proposed well we haven't we haven't even
seen what they are yet so there's it's
premature to be to be out
um giving specific comments Nate but as
I said this is something we already do
uh at Delta We already pay uh
compensation this last year in hundreds
of millions of dollars for customers
which I don't think people appreciate as
a level of time but we do it at Delta
because it's great service that's why
you travel on us is that you know if
something goes awry Delta's going to be
there for you yeah and people don't do
stories about the satisfied customers
they do the one the ones about the
people sleeping in the Airport overnight
and you know what do you never believe
what happened
um you know I am curious about AI uh
three years ago you guys started using
AI to help with travel disruptions
helping make decisions where are you
today with
integrating AI into the way you do
business well Tech technology and
digital and AI these are continued
advances and whether it's how we better
manage turbulence with respect to flight
and and atmospheric conditions all the
way down to we announced uh this year
that we're rolling out free Wi-Fi on our
planes and it's over the course of the
next year it's going to be worldwide on
Delta it's free it's fast it's high end
high speed and customer customers are
adopting it quickly we've the only the
only requirement we have is you'd be a
member of our our skymos program so you
can you can log into the system could
you incorporate television in all of
your things you know some Delta flights
have them some don't where you get
satellite TV while you're on flight I
love watching TV Ed in real time well
was there anything you could do about
that we are doing that so we never stop
taking the TV screens off the plane some
some uh some Airlines did yeah but some
just have movies I mean live TV yeah he
doesn't want to do this streaming thing
yeah yeah yeah
we we have DirecTV okay on our planes
and it's it's not on International
because we don't have the international
rights but it's on almost all of our U.S
planes there's still a handful that
don't have some of the smaller plants
over there Ed was uh with customer
satisfaction you know in the summer they
have summer Fridays you could have
summer Fridays everybody flies for free
to the city of your choice
I'll take that back and put it what now
yeah yeah um Gail you might want to get
you a private jet
we can do that too by the way thank you
so much I want one of those actually
thank you guys sincerely